welcome back man we missed you brother
hey man thanks for having me
hey man rapport was in there and he was
uh
well well you were missed rapport sat in
that seat and he
freaked out he thought he would get
coveted in here yeah although he's had
the black lung since i've known him he
coughed
he coughs non-stop by the way he's
definitely in the at-risk
group isn't he overweight yeah he's got
to be over 70 at this point
yeah yeah i think so yeah he he um
he's a little overweight he's a little
older he's already got that cough
like he's had the cop since i've known
him it's gotten worse she's like nah i'm
fine dude you know i've had this i'm
like not to that degree but
you're fine and then on friday we did a
bonus episode with scotty
mcknight who i played college football
with and uh
he does a lot of producing sky by the
way scotty mcknight sounds like he
should have been in new kids on the
block
scotty mcknight you know scotty mcknight
sounds like or he sounds a little yes
like 98 degrees like that's that's a
definitely boy band name porn star
scotty never mind scotty mcknight dude
scotty mcknight does sound like like he
would he would be a dirk diggler type
yeah it almost sounds like a fake name
yeah scotty mcknight he's a small white
guy who's one of the greatest receivers
to ever come out of unc colorado set all
the records
stunned his best friend's mark sanchez
yeah
who you know obviously usc new york jets
what
i'm really known for i'm sorry what's he
known for are you saying the butt fumble
there you go yeah it's [ __ ] up but by
the way dude when you say
jets usc everyone's like who and you're
like the butt fumble guy got it
right how [ __ ] up is that is that
weird i mean
but but like if you if you've used
something that
iconic isn't the right word but that
it's
maybe the most famous fumble
ever uh right or the
no there's been some where they've lost
like games but like that one maybe the
franco harris one that you
don't know but this one was so
embarrassing
and it was my my only thing with this is
see i don't give a [ __ ] they're already
down 14 nothing to doing lately that's
when new england was
straight new england yes so i think they
won the super bowl that year so
very it's not like it was a game
decision no it depends how your brain
set you know i'm saying like when you
think of tony romo what do you think of
uh i i don't think of that [ __ ] up
that fumble i don't think that fumble
but i do
i do think of him not winning playoff
games interesting
i don't think of that well like when you
think of conor mcgregor what do you
think of
i think of a showman didn't know
like no fight of his sticks out no i
think if someone think of knock him
knocking out
aldo in like 19 seconds i think that's
all part of the showman part
it goes i think i think do you know what
i mean like i think
he's a guy that got it really early
like mayweather like hey this is who i'm
gonna be
because i'm gonna make the most [ __ ]
money i can when i say mike tyson what
do you think of
i think of knockout specialist like i
think he was a bad man i
i that's interesting but again i think
exciting
not showman though mike tyson yeah not
showman i don't
like i think savage yeah i do that's
interesting but i think of knockouts
his and other peoples but i think of
knockouts
i don't i i don't think of a boxer per
se
i just think now right i just think of
not
like the hangover but think about this
when you when i think about tyson
i'm not sure i even think about his
knockout i think about buster douglas
i remember watching that fight it was a
big moment do you know what i mean i
remember watching that fight so it's
interesting interesting i re we were i
remember where i was i was in naples
florida
we were having a family reunion insane
it
took the world maybe the most shocked
i've ever been after a hundred percent
well okay for me that one
the giants patriots super bowl still to
me to this day the dave tyree
catch and all that cut him the next year
yes
sports in a nutshell i know right once
the super bowl congrats
yeah what can't use you anymore what did
you think about
and by the way that's what i love the
most about sports i i don't like that
the patriots lost because i'm patriots
fan
but in a way i do in a way
i like that that team that undefeated
team undefeated
i like and the biggest haters on the
planet the 72 dolphins
they get together every year when they
look at those guys
yeah but i like the fact dude that that
just
to me encapsulated sports which is you
never know
on any given day when these dudes if
they're gelling
together yeah so i i i know i didn't
like it
in the moment but looking back on it
that was that's
yeah man your boy tom brady looked a
little rusty yesterday okay let's talk
about yesterday's games
so first of all did no fans bother you
not at all meaning because they did a
great job with the camera angles where
you you didn't even really see them and
there was a little the only one where it
bumped me out was sunday night with the
rams
and the dallas cowboys yeah they kept
showing this amazing the mostly you know
it's a five billion dollar statement the
most ex
expensive stadium in the world they kept
showing with no fans like
we got it we got it yeah you keep
reminding us nobody's in there they show
jerry jones by himself
literally by himself by the way skybox
i'm like go down lower dude did you
see the way he put his hand over his
heart for the national anthem
uh jerry jones nobody can you do i
i didn't know if he was having a stroke
or if this he had a bob dole hand
but his hand up a sign his hand was real
cramped
look look what's going on
he looks like it might be arthritis he
looks like you know what you know
he looks like dr evil dude he looks like
like he looks like a weird dude he looks
like the bad like what's his name from
the simpsons
uh oh damn it what's his name uh you
know
no mr mr burns he looks like mr burns
look at that hand like
and he kept it like that from counting
what's with this hand here like what
what is this
what the [ __ ] someone said uh take my
strong hand
let me get my strong hand on the [ __ ]
man
i will say last night's game though to
me
was the game it's so funny take my
strong hand
last night's game was without a doubt
the two most
not i'm saying not saying they're bad
the two most overrated quarterbacks in
football
uh dax prescott backpress got off
jared goff is a professional athlete
with no muscle tone which i find
very weird he looks squished like skinny
fat almost
yeah they they paid that's why the rams
are kind of [ __ ] they won last night
price shouldn't know but
the the rams invested so much in goff i
just don't think he's a franchise
quarterback how are you a franchise
quarterback if you have leonardo
dicaprio's body
yeah what the [ __ ] is happening there
yeah
it's strange right because you got me
those guys work out they have to don't
they but it's just you know but
to his point tom brady's not gonna win
any awards on his body
no never no ever you ever seen him at
draft the draft and gives me hello
oh she gave every slow white kid hope
that you could too
be one of the greatest to ever do it now
dex prescott is built like a brick [ __ ]
yes yeah yeah and by the way i don't
think he's a bad
fan i don't think he's a bad quarterback
i don't think he he is a quarterback who
is going to
win you the you know what super bowl the
super bowl you know
example like look they're stacked
talent-wise yeah but i should be
doing way better let me ask you a
question about troy aikman overrated
or did he play did he play on a great
team or is troy aikman taking a team by
himself
like so to me mahomes i think russell
wilson
is the best quarterback me too okay and
that's not a knock on my homes but if
you gave me and i texted you this
yesterday
yes you said you would you say i said
were you super bowl you're down by six
you have two minutes to go
final drive you taking my homes or
wilson we both say we'll see yeah it
takes you right
wilson like right away right away and
that's so
crazy because i think mahomes will might
go
down as being the best ever but that's
weird russell doesn't get his due
but but i can't imagine picking
anybody besides that guy he
he just seems like yesterday he went 31
for 35 bro
nuts dude nuts against other
professional football players nuts
so i'm i'm i yeah and brady struggles
they just look like i think they're
going to be fine to get to the
championship
uh but it's just like
i think it was a feeling out process
also this one if you're a brady fan this
is what
should worry you is that he didn't have
much time at all no granted they're
probably playing the best team in the
league the saints but
he didn't have much time at all oh [ __ ]
he has no help
and they're stacked they need to j i
think they're going to gel they got a
lot so many new pieces i mean
it's going to take a minute they just
looked rusty i agree with that they look
rusty but i will say
bronch look 90 years old finn but but
also he didn't do anything no
but he looked small man yeah he looked
real thin like he's on brady's kind of
regiment uh are you talking about
steroids and avocados yeah
if tom brady's on steroids dude he's on
he's on the wrong kid he's on something
why why do you why do you think that 42
43
yeah i mean it could be peptides it
could be hgh
at that level why wouldn't you what's
what explain what peptides are
peptides are like a branch so it's like
you could do peptides where it's like
or sarms where it's like aversion
technically it'd be a
illegal substance but it's harder to
track shorter
shorter half-life stuff like that but
what does it do what do peptides do is
it helps
like hgh or peptides raise your
testosterone build muscle
leaner you know at 42 like you don't
think lebron's on [ __ ]
i think basketball players are
i honestly if you're asking me should
football players
be allowed to have some help i say yes i
say the amount
their bodies get beat up to think that
they're not doing something to recover
right so i and i i honestly don't
if you put it on the table and said
here's what's going to be legal
everybody
we do want this we want you guys to be
able to recover we want you guys to be
healthy
we don't want to mask the injuries with
uh uh you know painkillers we want to
help you recover from the injury if
you're investing in your product hgh and
the recovery process it seems like the
i wouldn't why wouldn't you why'd you
think they are
why do you think they are they are
pretending like they don't want the
because i think it's pretending they
have to but yeah it's all optics like
they if you fail an nfl steroid test
it's just a it's basically uh iq tests
like you know during the season where
we're getting tested
unless you do get put in that protocol
where they're testing every week
right because you got busted before but
usually it's an iq test
because and i had heard with mba they
tell you baseball too they tell you when
they're gonna test
like they're all playing the game you
they just they have to
optics have the test now the one that
who doesn't is the ufc
they can test you anytime well you suck
because they hired an
outsourcing you know kind of uh
party third party that comes and tests
you know we're hiring you
you're in control we have nothing to do
with it and they test you randomly
365 days a year multiple times like but
i think that's
more important than the other sports
because i think
if there's one person who's doping
and another person isn't you one person
in that sport somebody can die football
too though yeah
yeah i think for football honestly it's
more about recovery for those guys don't
you think like
because i've heard and again i don't
i've never
played professional football believe it
or not but i've heard those guys aren't
really even up and
walking until that's why the players
hate when they do
the turnaround so if they play on sunday
and they go oh you're also playing
thursday night like
dude you're giving me four days to
recover it's not enough
yeah i think that the players hate when
they play on sunday and then play on
thursday
they [ __ ] hate it this this this
particular go around
like you know i think the rams have two
east coast
games the next two weeks i think that's
what i read but because of covid they
can't stay
out there so whoever made the schedules
they should
fly back they're gonna fly back so
whoever me a river though you know
so you gotta get back on your private
jet but they should i i agree for them
for them it's like no it sucks dude yeah
i know we fly private but
yeah we don't stay out here yeah we
don't have to go fast forward
i wonder man i really do wonder if
because my brother was like i don't
think home field advantage matters in
the nfl this year and i said
actually i think it might matter yeah
because they get a stay because they get
to stay
in just peace of mind i think people
feel doesn't matter for the nba this
year because the
right that's why you're seeing kind of
these weird teams do well like my
[ __ ] nuggets in game seven with the
clippers
who were projected to win it all but
dude the nuggets got their number
how first of all shitty bodies my boy
djokovic is doing work dude
back to back 16 point comebacks in the
second half
isn't it great back to back if i'm doc
rivers
this concerns me back to back 16 point
not good no no no no no that that really
concerns me because
the lakers are better than the nuggets
that's this what's interesting and we
can move on after this
not to get balls deep in basketball but
the lakers
the nuggets actually match up better
with the with the with the lakers and
the clippers so if you're a lakers fan
because jokic yeah they're just are the
way we play the game yeah if you're a
lakers fan you should be worried if the
nuggets win
who's guarding on your from your squad
who's guarding lebron
that's what that's the first thing i
always go to who gar because on the well
if you think
if you think rondo's going to be your
savior as your third man
no he's not so we got porter baller
right who's i don't know who's guarding
lebron i know you guys got
a bunch of guys who can score on any
given we we got murray right murray
who's a monster but
a porter but also like all right lebron
can go off do your thing dude we have
all sorts of answers we got a great
bench
we got the best center in the game in
djokovic she's been an ad
we got best center the nba
agrees he was first team all pro first
team all pro
better than a.d wow
i bet if you ask coaches too who would
you rather have in your team every
single coach would pick djokovic
oh i don't know man a.d seems like such
a singular talent
but i can't come i can't argue that i'm
just saying if you're a lakers fan which
you know i'm both did you see
joking hit that fadeaway off a one leg
three-pointer monster over morris
monster my boy murray
oh my god you think porter's gonna end
up being the big steal of the draft
oh yeah well he's kind of a steal right
because he's supposed to be
projected top five gets hurt then i can
still draft him takes a year off look
dude he's a [ __ ]
baller he only played two games in
kahala
great are you are you also a broncos fan
huge broncos fan so you're gonna watch
tonight [ __ ] yeah
how do you feel about this game tonight
how do you feel about the the broncos
well here's the thing my boy
uh will compton plays for the titans
yeah and i love him he does
busting with the boys podcast will's my
boy he just resigned with the titans
i don't pers well and then one of my
best friends is the strength and
conditioning coach for the broncos
he's literally one of my best friends
he's my coach from football the ufc
so i want the bronx to do well but i
want will to do well i just want a good
game i should say
but bronco i grew up die hard broncos
yeah you did you grow up
i started going to my high stadium
like that was a big deal i've always
said and again i could be 100 wrong
but i've always said the only thing that
kept john elway
from being watch your mouth now i meant
from being he's my lord and savior
you're talking to somebody who thinks
elway should be held in higher esteem
as far as all-time greats pretty high i
think without dan reeves i think if he
had had a different
if he had so say if he if he had had a
schuler
who had been like because it seemed to
me dan reeves was like run the ball run
the roll over on the ball
now go win the game in the fourth
quarter yeah so he didn't let him build
up a whole ton of stats
he's a baller though dude i think elway
deserves
more credit if possible i think in a
different system
with a different coach you're talking
about a dude whose numbers
are through the [ __ ] roof he was the
first guy
who could do what aaron rodgers does
which is sprint out to my right
and then i'm gonna throw a [ __ ] rope
savage a
rope savage you know who deserves more
credit if i if i could go back in time
they say
you can start a franchise we're going to
surround with the best players you can
pick one quarterback
yeah from the past 50 years you know who
i'd pick wait wait you're telling me you
think this is the best quarterback of
all time
oh can i guess yeah what era
uh same area as elway dan marino yep
yeah
listen man not and he was also featured
in my favorite movie of all time major
intro yeah it's hard to argue
it's hard to argue dan marino was a
[ __ ]
savage yeah dude his release was like
just because he doesn't
didn't win a super bowl no one wants to
give the guy credit it's like damn
burrito dude
played with nobody in today's day and
age if you if he
because you can't bump and run in
today's day and age with his release
he's destroying
all records i uh not even [ __ ] guess
like drew brees
you know what dan maria would do 2020
[ __ ] in his time
with that his a little afro coming from
pig
oh he had a he had great bar mitzvah
hair look at that [ __ ]
i will tell you something by the way you
know who i hate to play
watch play but i love his game because
he talks so much [ __ ]
look i love how much [ __ ] philip rivers
talks i love him but man whenever he
throws the ball
it looks like it's too heavy for him
he's like oh he's he's getting older too
oh
he's he's pushing it out there dude it's
tough to watch
how about the ratings for that thursday
like you didn't even know it was on i
think it's
not good lois they've debuted that i
think down uh 18 percent
but terrible marketing terrible
marketing i i think
it the sunday night football season
davey rains fall from until 19. all
right
how far how how long sunday nights
though i think it's a number of things
i think it's uh the protesting that
stuff people are so [ __ ] sick
of and then i think it's there's so much
going on
we didn't know it was coming back yeah
because there was no preseason
like like my father-in-law we sat down
yeah and uh
we sat down and he goes man it's crazy
uh it's crazy that brady and brees in
the third quarter still
i was like excuse me it was crazy you
guys still playing
it's pre-season i was like no it's not
he thought it was the preseason
he thought it was still pre-season he's
like when's the real thing started like
right now right now dude get the [ __ ]
out yeah but it's like
he's a common comment like he has no
idea i had no idea
look sunday night football
that is okay 22 to 14. it's a steep
decline till
19 last year's so yeah i mean you're
down
[ __ ] dude you're down basically seven
million
that's a lot hey homeowners are you guys
thinking about
home warranty coverage with an american
home shield plan
you're prepared when stuff breaks down
in your home listen i'm a home
owner stuff breaks down all the time
it's worrisome it's so expensive i'm
talking about the not so easy to fix
sometimes pretty expensive stuff like a
refrigerator
heating air conditioning my air
conditioning just broke down
plumbing and electrical and believe me
when it happens
you're really going to be glad you have
a plan in place so you're not so
stressed out about things
to see what american home shield covers
and save 50
off any plan go to ahs.com
fighter that's ahs.com
fighter ahs.com fighter that's ahs.com
fighter for 50 off any plan american
home shield be sure with the shield
limitations exclusions apply sea plan
for details the holiday season is right
around the corner and this year we know
the people will be buying more stuff
online than
ever before especially in the world we
live in right now if you're an
e-commerce seller
and you're ready to meet the demands for
record-breaking online
shopping season be ready with ship
station
when you're selling online get a massive
amount of orders out quickly
can be exhausting and tough all right
that's why
we choose shipstation.com is the fastest
easiest
most affordable way to manage and ship
your orders just a few clicks your
managing orders you're printed out
you're ready to go man ship station
takes the hassle out of holiday
shipping shipstation helps online
sellers get orders out quickly save
money
on shipping costs and keep customers
happy no matter what you're selling
amazon etsy your own website shipstation
brings all your orders
into one simple interface shipstation
works with all major cares including
usps fedex ups
even international we got you guys
covered no wonder shipstation is the
number one choice of online
sellers so right now the firing kid
listeners can try shipstation free for
60 days when you use the code fighter
make sure your business is ready to meet
the demands of a massive
online shopping season get started at
shipstation.com today
click on the microphone top of the
homepage type in fighter
that's shipstation.com then enter code
fighter
shipstation.com makeship happen uh
what'd you do this weekend though
brother
well jacob came home besides sucking off
biden
uh jacob came home my son where was he
he was
touring the national parks for an amazon
prime show well that's cool
man so great did he go to yellowstone
he went to uh glacier national out in
montana
so okay where do you fall on people
getting super close to wild animals not
my thing
pros cons yeah pro
i get a cool instagram pic with a
grizzly bear one con
heats me asked for yeah live on
instagram tv
you know what i'm saying that's exactly
where i fall like so was he taking
pictures of the wild animals so he
showed me he was like there was this one
there was a herd of bison that were
across the street
and i couldn't it wasn't close enough so
i hopped the fence
and i'm like stop right there was the
camera crew with him or something did he
do it for the tv show no just for his
instagram jacob
i agree i go what i go how is that has
you not seen the videos what bison do to
people
dude have you ever seen those videos yes
have you ever seen a buffalo
in person i grew up in [ __ ] colorado
we see buffalo they're massive they're
massive and they're not cool no here's
what i would tell you
they're they're hippos covered in hair
and horns bison or hippos
if you're if you're an animal and you
have a dirt hippo
boom bob this could be you jacob
look look in the air
and look at that boom [ __ ] oh it's a
hairy rhinoceros
that's what that is when you have knives
on your face you're not friendly
that's not but again just pros cons dude
go to the zoo if you want to get close
that's my saying like what what's the
why why
why why are you going he said i really
wanted to see a bear
what you want to see a bear i have no
desire to do that no
i don't i've seen a bear on google yeah
yeah yeah i've seen with the zoo i mean
sure he's depressed and like
broken yeah and he's wearing he's
wearing a hat yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's like that's like
an alien come here like i want you out
humans and go
to prison oh like looks i'm like they
look pretty sad yeah
that's what we do with animals hang in
there they look real sad i heard
an interview with a guy who spent time
in prison
and maybe wait you might have told me
the same thing
who was like i kind of miss it oh yeah i
got a buddy who's like
he was doing some bad stuff he's like ah
there's something in the world if i go
back
it's actually pretty awesome i was like
huh yeah he's like you're just with your
boys all day
there's kind of a schedule we like
hanging out like well you're pitching it
to me pretty i mean should we rob a bank
like yeah i mean like how do i get in
i but i was but but they were like you
know because it's you
there's what this dude was talking about
he was like you just
know what your day-to-day is there's no
guessing
and i was like do you know go in the
military yeah
enter the mouth do do do yourself or
just set yourself a schedule
dude get on a club basketball team ah
yeah
like i don't know what get yourself set
yourself a schedule dude
dude speaking of your son going around
all these national parks dude
i have you watched yellowstone
no cat have you watched yellowstone with
kevin costner
no so so i talked about them below the
belt i got a ball demon dude
i put i have a cowboy hat i wear a
cowboy hat and i'm in my underwear and i
drink whiskey when i watch yellowstone
it's get the [ __ ] out of here top five
all-time series for me it is
so [ __ ] good do you have a hat like
that i do do you have a picture of this
hat or you i'm
gonna take pigs free we're gonna watch
tonight i'm gonna take pictures off
blast on the internet now let me
so you go whiskey underwear american
whiskey because i'm
a japanese whiskey guy but i when i'm
watching yellowstone because they're so
goddamn american they drink a lot of
whiskey
i drink uh buffalo trace american
whiskey yeah
i have a cowboy hat on and i [ __ ] can
i tell you something embarrassing what's
up so one time i was in i went to
college in san antonio
and uh college a call called trinity oh
yeah
so not a lot of jews at trinity so i
um we're out one night and uh
i i'm there's this woman she was like 31
which that time that's old man sure meet
her out at this bar
and she was just basically i got a free
night basically she was with her friends
she basically was like i got a free
night and i'm ready to [ __ ] yeah they
don't mess around
yeah and i i was on board so i go back
and i'm 22 i was 21 or 22. go back to my
place now
my game plan is i just gotten a guitar
she said it's my birthday
can you play me a song guitar and i was
like
i didn't really i just got in like two
weeks before so i was like yeah
you know yeah come on back i'm gonna
figure something out for you she goes
can you play me happy birthday i'm like
absolutely i play happy birthday so my
game is this is the plan
she's driving back in her car i'm
driving back in mine
i'm going to get the guitar out and
you know noodle around a little bit yeah
whatever yeah but just a little bit yeah
but
but maybe acapella a little happy
birthday and see if i can't slide right
into the panties
i come home my buddy tim tim was jacked
jack jack jack tim is wearing tidy
whities
hell yeah cowboy hat did he get on a
drum set or some [ __ ]
nope he's this is how he used to watch
tv tidy wadi's cowboy hat
get a half gallon of milk and a plain
baked potato and he would drink the milk
and eat the baked potatoes jesus christ
this dude was a baseball player no he
was
just a jack just jacked and [ __ ]
bananas
right and and he would drink the milk
out of the side of his mouth so he could
eat so
it was always dripping oh wow so he come
home and he's sitting there and he
wouldn't sit on the couch
he would sit crisscross applesauce in
front of the couch and watch tv
so we come home and i get this groaning
last woman with me
[Music]
and so i'm like hey and she comes in and
she sees tim i'm like hey tim and he's
like hey man
and so he's just sitting he's sitting
there and he's drinking his milk and
he's eating his baked potato and um
and uh she sits on the couch a little
ways down from him and
i'm like can i get you a drink she said
cool and
i go hey i just gotta use the restroom
real quick and i hand her a drink and i
go to the bathroom and i go to the
bathroom and
i'm talking myself up 31's oh at that
age yeah
that's a grown person oh yeah and
especially when you're in college
i'm psyching myself up i'm honestly you
ever when you were younger were you ever
worried about
performing sexually with somebody who
you thought was way more experienced
than you oh yeah
so that was my big thing i was just like
ah she's gonna
she's gonna she's gonna say something
like what are you doing yeah do you know
what i mean i know you're amateur
yeah dude and so my plan was i was
talking myself
my plan was like i was going to say it's
your birthday so you tell me what to do
that was going to be my gift to you it's
whatever you want that's what my dad is
like i'm going to learn without being
embarrassed right
good plan i said it a couple times in
the mirror yeah you know i was playing
it up i was like what do you want me to
do yeah more than i tried my birthday
yeah i tried a little matter of fact
birthday girl it's you're not yeah it's
just
you know it was basically the song from
twins tonight is your night bro
you know right so i had it all psyched
up and i walk out
and i maybe was in the bathroom a little
longer and i thought the tv is still on
the milk and the potato are there but
tim and the girl are gone
oh tim's [ __ ] so i look in the
kitchen gun tim's jack dude
tim it's jack jack same six one
a solid 240 oh wow no like
dies like a solid a guy who you were
like
even if he was wearing his tidy weddings
and a cowboy hat and you walked in you'd
be like yeah that's makes sense yeah
i'm on board with that he's basically
mike all stuck yeah yeah i'm like you're
doing good you're doing good
i got no argument and so i looked down
into his room
and he just had the cowboy hat on his
doorknob and i was like
so i just kind of i did a couple of
light light just
just light you know what i mean the
light are you guys in there yeah i did a
couple of light locks
but i just the first night lock was
hello and the second like now what goes
i just
i didn't know if you still wanted me to
play happy birthday
somebody's birthday in here she's all
get out yeah dude
it was nice you mad at your buddy you
understand no good for you
yeah if in a seven minute period you
could turn the game around that quick
i i don't even know if that's worth if i
don't know if that's more of his game or
her just being [ __ ] hungry
i think she looked at my body and his
he was like i'm gonna go with this guy
she knew she was not going for a
boyfriend she was just out to get
[ __ ] she was 31 who wanted to date a
younger guy or have
sex with a younger guy he's there in his
underoos already with a cowboy hat on
knowing what your p she knows what he's
packing he's wearing he's got
body and his underoos on he might as
well just oscillate i thought
you know he's probably a little simple
with milk in the potato a hundred
percent okay peanut butter falcon let's
do this
yeah that's exactly what it was that's
what happened
and and by the way i had to listen to
them [ __ ] oh man
it was like and he came in did he say
anything when
when he came out so he came out right
and they finished and i went into my
room i didn't want i was in the living
room right
because my room was near there in the
room so i mean i don't want to hear
too much you want to stand outside the
door and jack off no
no no it's college so that's the kids i
think that's what kids do
so she walks right past me
and he comes and sits down
picks up the milk picks up the baked
potato carries back carries right back
in
what a savage yeah and he just sat there
for a second and he was
he just looked at me he goes sorry about
that i was like man whatever wow you're
a good guy yeah man what do you get
listen what do you he didn't say like
man that was a real wild cat
later because he i go how was it he was
like man she was grown up
but mama knew what she liked yeah jesus
christ yeah i
i i don't like i don't like the guys
that tell you all the details if they
hook up
i don't need to know what the [ __ ] dude
i don't need to i need a podcast on the
girl you [ __ ] on friday
i've never i don't need a podcast dude
i've never needed never
i'm like i don't i don't care dude i
wasn't there it's not my dick
i don't give a [ __ ] dude yeah yeah he is
that's strange yeah you like you wanna
know my best move
like dude what whoa hey don't need a
podcast and you're hooking up with
chicks
the only time i've told stories is when
they're embarrassing for me
correct like the first time i ever went
down on a girl
so i was probably
15 and uh
we were both drinking and i'm like i'm
gonna try to go down with this girl
so are you at your parents house no no
no i'm at her
her dad rented her an apartment
when she was 15. yeah there's gonna be
some issues there yeah sure
so like he lived down the hall but she
still she's a bad parent is that the
right isn't that the stup
bad parenting one at all oh she was like
nobody lives down the hall i'm like
but we can come here whenever and she
was like yeah he never he does i said
does he have a key and she said no oh
wow
okay is that bad's bad parenting right
okay it could have ended well for her
yeah it didn't end well no no yeah so
but anyways
i go down on her and so
this is so embarrassing so i'm
i'm uh i don't know what how long it's
supposed to happen or sure
really what's supposed to what i'm
supposed to do i still don't yeah
so i and i come back up as i'm coming
back up
um i just heard oh
she fell asleep so
she was asleep stuff so when we were
leaving
i was telling my boys oh i knocked her
the [ __ ] out
you know what i mean so good night it's
so good
so when i was in school you know i was
coming back talking i was like yeah
y'all
and my there's a dude um
i think it was kevin campbell and i was
telling him he was like yeah bro
she said she first oh she told her
school i was like oh no
man who tells the school yeah but i
don't mind like
that's a story i'll tell now because
it's funny when you go down on the girl
and she falls asleep yeah it's a that's
a bummer
that's a bummer that's a bummer have you
ever had anything super embarrassing
happen to you in bed
where you were like don't tell anybody
no i remember my
my first girlfriend we were hooking up
and uh we're getting hot in heaven she
farted
like loud right on my hand and
you know you're like on your hand yeah
yeah that was my first question you were
i was i was playing with her you got it
so almost like in your hand like again
like hard
and i could tell she was so embarrassed
could you feel the oh dude
on your hands i was [ __ ] like she was
on a
like she was farted on a bleacher let me
ask you another question
i just smell it later well no i just
pretend like she was like
i literally just was how old were you
uh 16. oh well [ __ ] dude i was just like
okay
that's terrible but at 16
zero deal breakers is it well she was my
girlfriend yeah but it was also like
okay like you don't really know how to
react in a situation you know no
i was just like yeah is this supposed to
happen and i just pretended it didn't
happen
i wanted to die is what i wanted to do i
wanted somebody to beam me up like star
trek get me the
[ __ ] out of there dude i think i would
have thought at 16
that that just happened when you
you were you had your finger where you
were i would have thought maybe i pushed
a button
and that's what happened but i knew
exactly what happened she farted
i yeah i don't it was so embarrassing i
okay my you fart around your girl now
yeah i fart honor
oh interesting interesting i fired honor
i remember
we went a long time chin you be fighting
on your girl no
no are you are you do you fart in front
of each other no we she doesn't want to
do it i don't want to do it i don't
either i don't know you know
me and my girl been the other seven
years never never never once
i never did until she said it's okay if
you fart in front of me and i said to
her
this is a pandora's box how long were
you guys together
like day two no we were probably
two years in yeah and she was like you
know it's totally okay and i said just
you know
like this is a bad move for you because
now that you say it's okay
you have no idea isn't it weird how
funny farts are
like my son told like you know he's four
so how far he finds them funny
and i go dude you can do this at home
and you can do this when you get outside
in the playground
but don't do this in school he goes
why'd daddy go because another girl's
gonna like you dude you don't wanna be
fart boy yeah so wait till you get
outside
so you know he he listens right you
don't be fart boy
so he he got in the car picked him up on
friday from school
he get in the car and i go i always go
how was your day buddy he was good
and i go what happened and he could not
stop laughing because his friend
alex farted in front of a girl and he
could not stop laughing he was telling
me the story because he was laughing i
was laughing
and i was like i'm 37 laughing at these
four-year-olds farting
dude we were hysterically laughing and i
go did you laugh in front of you
i didn't dad i didn't i walked away and
laughed in the corner because i didn't
want to embarrass him
that's super sweet that i the fart is
always funny
i have my favorite kind of fart is the
walk fart my dad is the master all dads
are they're walking farther
is there a frog out here every time dude
yeah
is that you have no other new material
every time like he was out here last
year and farted went on a hike
yeah because they're frogs out here in
california i go still
you're you would that's your goat jay
leno you've done a new set
in how many years i oh i think farts are
always funny i don't know that
you'll ever convince me that they're not
i think
that anybody who says that they aren't
funny just won't laugh at them around
you they're if somebody a fart
is always funny in front of the right
crowd oh yeah
in without a doubt and and and a
and a well-placed like one of those dude
i saw somebody i think it was bar stool
this
this girl uh her roommates film it she's
like uh she's like
my roommate didn't want to fart in front
of her boyfriend so she walked into the
other room
and they're laughing she's feeling it
she rips the biggest fart
have you seen it have you seen it right
was on barstool yeah i was on barstool
it was so [ __ ] funny i also am a big
fan of the
lightning farts on fire and your [ __ ]
oh wow yeah yeah
i i'm i'm look i like weird
[ __ ] i think it's bar stool but it was a
newer post
i think this just no not that one that's
not i would go to their
instagram yeah yeah or their or their
website
oh is it on their instagram yeah it
it's always funny and for whatever
reason
you can always get
especially kids kids when they're born
they laugh at a fart oh yeah my my uh
nine-month-old will laugh his ass off
is it in here i thought it was i mean
i'm sure they're posting a [ __ ] ton
because of football
for football season i'm sure they really
ramp it up okay
is that it here we go so it says
dude is definitely doing the same thing
in the other room so like she goes when
your roommate has to come into your room
to fart
because her boyfriend is here listen
know them
it sounds like somebody laughing in the
corner
it says
it's just [ __ ] ridiculous ah so you
should but you're
this weekend so your son came home son
came home man it's been gone for how
long
month and a half we were psyched to have
to watch yellowstone with your son
i'm definitely gonna we're definitely so
[ __ ] good dude
it's so good i want to move to montana
by the way
i hope they do a second season of love
on the spectrum
if they don't it will be an atrocity
agree
that guy michael is the single most
likable person
ever on in the history of television in
the history of television i'm like
this is the now the girl i found the
most unlikeable character
she was a little one who danced around a
little bit farted and burped in front of
the guy and then was kind of like at
high standards
yeah she was kind of an [ __ ] this guy
here
oh dude is he the most likable guy ever
in the history first of all he's the
friendliest little guy of all time
but the other guy too the guy who's uh
kelvin uh
the one uh the third one in a top road
oh he was so
nice he was that i like how honest there
go well
it's uh i think we're better off as
friends but i do need friends so i'd
like to contact you in the future
it's so it's so nice what i didn't know
about autism
is how much of it was a social like how
of the the social issues
but i find the direct
the direct truth refreshing with no
emotion
so interesting it's very like there's
they don't blur any lines no
like the like they'll be on the day and
they go you know i just feel like you're
not my type i'm more into asians and
you're
red yeah and it's not my thing she goes
okay yeah do you think this is going
well
no got it oh do you like video games
yeah me too yeah and it's like it's on
i it's so i find it like it's like oh
cool
and one of the guys was like when the
interviewer asked him said
what do you think will be the biggest
issue for you and he's
to know what your biggest issue is he
said social issues
but to know it and not be able to do
anything about it like the human
condition in this is
so fascinating because you know what
else is great dude honestly
at the end of the day what really
connects people to this
is that you see the basic human issue of
just
wanting to connect with another person
well it's what this comes down to
you know i keep i say i'm a stats i see
the stats of
the people with autism finding love like
it's like
97 don't ever like get married it's such
a bummer but that is like it
shows you man there are a couple things
a couple shows that have helped me so
much during quarantine
alone was one of them and this one also
love inspectors you've got to start
yellowstone dude
but but yellowstone is a 90 day fiance
that's what i'm in beth beth isn't has
been a little
hesitant to start 90 day fiance why
she's still watching housewives
housewives i can't get it
listen i worked for bravo housewives is
so doctor and all that [ __ ]
dude 98 fiance some real [ __ ] son
it's real [ __ ] real problems what do you
think you'd have a better
idea better chance finding somebody with
the 90 day fiance
set up or the love is blind um
love is blind you'd have a better well
90 day fiance
it's like because this night day fiance
so it's to be someone
foreign right and it's always a little
weird yeah it's a weird dynamic they
want the green card
she's hot enough all right yeah yeah
yeah girl we'll figure it out
the love is blind love is blind is tough
right
i get it i didn't get through all of
love oh i found it boring
halfway through i was like i got it yeah
whatever happened to you
yes that happens every every year like
me for this that was me in sopranos
what yeah three episodes into it i'm
good no you don't get it
three episodes three up when's the last
time you watched it i went back and
watched the whole
first season mm-hmm four months i've
been home
recently yeah dude sopranos really
what part of it do you felt like you got
it was
i wasn't that interested in compared to
the tv we have now
yeah compared to that we've just it's
so much better now what would you say is
so much better
everything story lines the editing the
acting
oh boy what what show in particular
would you say is so much better
besides yellowstone well that is so much
better than this
for sure i'd say narcos all seasons are
better i haven't seen any narcos
but i haven't seen titanic either so
yeah that's fine though people have been
on me this week about
titanic holy [ __ ] man you do yourself a
service man i gotta tell you i had no
idea so many of your fans were big
titanic guys they're guys in their
feelings like how are you no one how do
you not see this
i haven't seen titanic i haven't seen
the notebook i'm not in my face no but
i'm not
yeah but titanic's a solid movie isn't
it just like
it's not you wouldn't consider that to
be a love story
yeah a chicken chunky flake no no not
really because leonardo dicaprio it's
that
titanic so it's a you know it's it's
pretty brutal at the end
yeah uh rose is a bit of a [ __ ] right
she's
really cocked he's in leo the whole time
yeah jack
and then like they could have took turns
on the on the
ship uh door which they were both
freezing you know
i mean true she could have shared a door
with him yeah
i think about it like we could have
taken turns so i didn't freeze to death
i also feel like i've
been told the movie so many times that
like you got
it i think that's where i met with
sopranos
got it but you don't though now i know
people can be upset about this but you
watch the wire
no i watched the first three episodes
and i was like i got it honestly i
watched the first video wow yeah we're
the same
yeah all right i'll tell you what man
that's true blood it's okay
i do watch true blood i like that kind
of campy stuff but i'm gonna
get into i'll go back and watch a wire
oh
it's heavy and towards the end it sucks
but you watch breaking bad
another one got it no you
i'm gonna tell you right now 100
breaking bad
got it you don't got i got it how many
episodes you got
i did four no you don't got it you don't
got
it breaking bad i know no man
i know dude no man watch ozark
nah i watched the first three episodes
and i think i got it why
why i did i watched the first video
yellow sona gets you right away it's so
well done
and the writer sheridan you'd love all
his stuff are you telling me
if you were telling me one out of the
three yellowstone the wire
or what was the other one you just said
ozark ozark which one what should i
watch
yellowstone fantastic okay kevin carson
name one bad thing he's ever done oh no
dude
i'm team cat now you could argue water
world but i found it entertaining as a
kid i am
team kevin crush sign me up
yeah man and by the way he was
so [ __ ] good as a young dude
i mean bodyguard come on
you would you put costner's career
up against say it tom hanks
ah
oh he's like a major movie star right
yeah tom hanks does not miss
never made a bad movie ah i've never had
to do tv
not that it's a bad thing he did bosom
buddies that's where he started that's
true
i'm saying you know like he's such a who
would you put her who would you put on
costner's left denzel washington
really same you think those two are the
same kind of level you look at their
like
their accolades it's like [ __ ] dude i
bet you is this kevin costner yeah if
you look at what's his eye will you go
right to his
imdb imdb i bet how many
how many credits do you think he's got
right off top your head without the
costume how many how many
how many credits you think he's got no
my boy you're talking about when he was
young
yeah because he i think he did some tv
okay so i think if we look at his
filmography i'm not looking
i think tom hanks gonna trump everybody
with the number
with uh as far as hits yeah box offers
money for sure dude you look at tom
hanks like holy [ __ ] box office money
force so so i bet you kevin costner has
been in
i'll give him 112 oh wow 112. you think
more than tom hanks
i think he probably did more bid stuff
maybe i don't know i say 112 things tom
hanks got
pretty famous pretty fast do you think
it big the movie big
yeah man that wasn't early on how many
credits you have am i close 112
let's see 61. that's not even close
oh dude john dutton he's john dutton
yellowstone
i want in the goddamn ranch dude c brand
me bro
i i but he's had more without a doubt
more big what is with the revision where
where do you fall on forrest gump i know
a lot of people now
hate it really so there's a lot of
there's you've been hanging out with
isis man there's there's big backlash
and going back and saying
what if you look what group are you
hanging out i don't agree
with you every tuesday
i don't agree with you but there are
some people who go have gone back now
and said forrest gump
not a good move get the [ __ ] out thank
you
trump is fantastic so i was on a date
with a girl in that movie
and dude there was a point in the movie
where i was tearing up right
and this was our second date and uh i
was about to lean over and go
it's a great movie right and she leans
over and she goes
are you crying and i was like what she
goes
are you [ __ ] crying the jenny part
she goes are you [ __ ] crying at this
movie
and i was like yeah and she was like
you shouldn't be just like that and i
was like dude first of all
another movie jenny real [ __ ] man
anything about jenny
the [ __ ] she drugged my boy forced gum
through just a real cocktails the entire
time
he was loyal then she gets aids dude
yeah
but i mean and then finally she does
this whole [ __ ] she's whoring out
she's playing guitar on the road he
sticks by her she's with that black
panther dude yeah
force beats his ass she's right or die
then finally
she's [ __ ] every guy in alabama gets
done she goes you know what
now i'll be with you yeah oh after he's
a billionaire started
apple yeah man but just i don't know
she's a whole lot of an [ __ ] man i
don't know a lot of
young hot women who are gonna be dating
[ __ ] guys
was he what that's the argument no one
knows what he has there's a thing on
instagram they not on instagram the web
like they're like what did forskoun have
and they've had experts look at it it's
asperger's that makes sense
i but i also don't know a whole lot i'd
love to see him on uh
full spectrum uh yeah i don't know a
whole lot of young women who are dating
just being honest they're not they're
not going all
in on asperger's bro i'll tell you right
now early on bill gates
or homeboy who owns amazon yes had
asperger's yes they're still getting
their dick sucked yeah every day
but look he finally got jedi when he had
a little doe
jenny was a [ __ ] [ __ ] hey look and
i'll tell you something else
young robin wright oh my god oh smoke
joe
uncomfortably google that what did
forrest gump have
i'm pretty sure asperger's is probably
right also he uh he has 92 credits as an
actor
thomas thomas yeah he had a 40 something
called the producer
thomas thomas tommy tommy how do you
feel about his son
in the jamaican accent not mad at it
makes me laugh
if your dad's force come it's gonna be a
tough world to navigate yeah it really
is yeah you're gonna be a white rapper
you know who else is a white rapper
tommy hilfiger's son really and he's
tied up all over his face how are your
bars if i was like not good
could you spin no not at all you know
it's uh
it's like something like you like you
have yeah like you know like little
dickie
or you know these guys they just have it
i don't have
that what would you say on a one zero to
ten if i was gonna be like your
freestyle zero zero are you a zero zero
i'm good with rhyming i can get four
lines out and then my brain goes
for me gump talk i'm seeing autism
i will tell us with autism yeah that but
but autism is
is uh isn't that aren't autism
asperger's
it's a spectrum it's in the spec on the
spectrum right
so i think they are
i but i think you know the more i
chose and the more i look into autism
and asperger's i think there are more
people i know
who might not have been diagnosed you
know when you saw love on the spectrum
buddies with some ass burgers
feel very aspergie or asperger who does
there are some people that both you and
i know yeah no i i i got a buddy who
he's so ridiculously smart
yeah but then his like connection verbal
skills you're like what the [ __ ] dude
yeah but you ask him like something
about history or this and he just
rattles off but as far as like so
personal socially it's like a nightmare
yeah when you're like did you just say
that out loud in front of everybody
right now but they're really good at
this one thing yeah you know they're
really smart in this area
i i am i think that
that telling the truth in public like
that
without being diagnosed has got to be
really
really difficult like because people
what should i do like have a card
no but like before we have a drink i
want you to know but you should say some
[ __ ]
no but that's what i mean but like how
difficult
must that be i can't even imagine dude i
can't imagine not being diagnosed that's
what i mean
right and you think that there's
something wrong but i have a friend
who's
uh like doesn't [ __ ] at all yeah
he's like always super truthful even it
hurts people's feelings
and i'm always scared to bring people
around him yeah
i'm like dude i'm telling you dude like
you [ __ ] you ain't called out on it
it's like [ __ ] dude but if you can't you
don't feel like safe to play
that's what i'm saying 100 but if he had
a
so you find yourself almost acting
different like reserved
because you don't want the backlash to
come on you does that make sense oh
that means you have a friend who's like
that and you're like oh god better watch
my p's and q's
or well dude there's also like
man you know they're a guy i have guys
that i grew up with
that that's their whole game they just
can't wait for you to say something
stupid oh that's my brother they're
gonna ride you
for a [ __ ] hour that's my brother i
mean
like like if you would have been like oh
how does uh a.d cover joking she's like
you [ __ ] and then ghost because he
knows him he doesn't have asperger's but
he knows
like the stats like oh like yeah like if
like the stats was talking about the
protest
he'll know all of them to a t and the
other side of it
and he's just waiting for you to poke
and then it's like
all right i don't care dude my guy was
literally just
yeah i don't need that it was awkward
silence in the car we're driving i went
hey i think the nuggets do against the
clippers and he goes off you're like all
right dude
again i don't need a podcast on the
nuggets clippers game seven
and you my brother will also in he'll
wait for me instead of saying jokic
if i said joe kick oh he would ride me
for an hour oh was that joe kick or you
know i was
joking when i did the podcast with rap
report we were talking basketball me and
rap know basketball but not like my
brother is black belt and basketball i
know all the stats everything
and after the podcast here that night he
sent me stats where i was wrong like hey
dude i don't give a [ __ ] yeah
you want to be stat boy you want to come
on the show and be the fact checker
you want to be that guy i'll hire you if
you want to be that guy yeah
i i i do when i get a show i bro science
everything
fact check twitter fact check is my
favorite checkpoint come
the [ __ ] actually larry bird only played
in 81
i don't like y'all i'm sorry i said 80.
my bad
there's nothing worse i kid it holds
like you'll be arguing like no larry
bird in the 80th game like exactly 77th
and i think all right
it's not information or facts that help
push this conversation no dude as a
matter of fact you're slowing it down
i don't need i this is one thing i miss
about people are not having their phones
on them all the time is because you
could actually just have a conversation
let's go [ __ ] you know let me check that
out that's me and my dad
oh yeah let me [ __ ] check that out
that's my dad i'll argue something and
then
two hours later it's done oh come on
bike
yeah you remember what you're saying
about that like what yeah yeah i don't
you're still ah dude get the i'm past
that it's like come on
i'm past that my brother i meant to tell
you
i don't mean interrupting uh i supposed
to uh i don't know if you notice i i
think it takes you that's supposed to
cap cities the end of the month yeah
cap city is shut down for good dude what
austin texas
my a staple of the top five club for me
in the country
easily top five club for me in the
country i was looking
so forward to it i and and i went hey
uh i'm starting the manager i go i'll do
the show for free yeah take i'll donate
all the money keep the lights on and
just
it's too late dude yeah i offered you
same thing i said do you need us to come
down and do some free show
whatever you want too late it's such a
bummer
it is such a iconic place
in such a cool cool room and the crowds
there were so good
now i think we both know somebody with a
[ __ ] ton of money
who's a comedian who just moved to
austin
i i would not be surprised to see a
comedy club open up there again i in
austin yes i want to open it up there in
that strip mall
not that i'm not crazy about the
location no it's not near the any
like where the people are no where would
you do it downtown closer
it would crush dude it's one of my
favorites i'm sure he's that we were
talking about romeo
i'm sure he's gonna do it to me what i
love the most about i told you i'm not
moving anymore right
yes you did i told you i am right i know
you're going to nashville
i'm really still comes back from
nashville this week
for good he just did a month he's just
doing him like people think he's moving
there theo just went out there to do
different guests for his podcast but he
lives here so he lives here yeah he
lives here he just went out there to mix
it up and he's
flying back and then he's that he might
do another three weeks out there he's
only doing three weeks
man you know i i when we we found the
place
i cannot wait to do it i don't know how
i'm gonna do my high life down there
because i don't know
how legal weed is in nashville oh they
don't i think we should be all right
cyrus lives there dude does she yeah by
the way do you know that's my dream
guest
of anything ever i've been on this i've
do you know that feel like you could
make that happen
i had to awkwardly convince
jacob i remember that to pretend like he
wanted a picture like
you can get her on i don't think so i do
i wish you an astronaut i would fan the
[ __ ] who would to you do you have an
ultimate guest
do you have anybody that you would fan
girl over i mean i'd say on hearing the
fans know this which i think they'd find
it weird i
fangirled over mark maron did you really
because i love his podcast i listen
i think he's the best interviewer in the
game he's been doing he's like a
godfather podcast
yeah i think he was surprised because we
came out here i was like dude do you
remember this
you remember when you were brad pitlin
and i think even brown was like dude
chill out
and you could tell mark's like oh [ __ ]
he actually listens to the podcast
like i'd love to be on spock what is it
about i just don't think i'm a match
because i think he hates athletes
he probably looks at me like an athlete
instead of a comic yeah i don't think
you'd have me on his pod
what do you what do you like the most
about his style
um i don't know he just gets him like to
open up and then
like with jerry seinfeld they've kind of
they've had their issues before
and he even talks about he's like i
could i just couldn't get through to
jerry i couldn't break that wall
and you can tell like he like he tries
to break that wall where they
they get out of their like promo or what
the [ __ ] they're on there foreign breaks
through it
i don't know i just like i'll ride my
bike and just listen to mark man he it
just
even if the guests i don't like really
care for i'll listen to it it's great
it's funny yeah i am you can tell a good
interviewer
when there are people on there that you
don't really care to listen to
and you're listening anyway yep that to
me like so that's a that's a sign that
that guy
connects with i i um even if skype
interviews which i hate skype
even his skype ones like he had jk
simmons on the other day it was [ __ ]
good man
he does he's he's scared of the work so
me i mean him politely
completely yes off but i don't i'll talk
about political stuff in the beginning
or cove and stuff and even when it comes
to code would mean him on opposite sides
but
it's not that i don't really i wouldn't
stop listening because of it i don't
respect him any less but dude some of
the smartest people i know are
you know opposite of what i believe it's
important to listen to smart people who
think the opposite of you oh i seek out
the opposite just
it actually helps your argument or helps
whatever point of view you have
a hundred percent uh it's one of the
reasons that i think that when people
when you
when you start to censor voices you
don't like it's super difficult
bad idea are you so
would you say that you're stand up
as you're doing more of it do you think
quarantine
or the time off stage has made you want
to push the envelope more on stage
like were you like you know what i
haven't been on stage in so long
i want to start [ __ ] talking about
this or i want to push it or do you feel
like
it's done the opposite um
i've never been that like i've never
been said
like political i've never said stuff
that really
poked the bear like that you know what i
probably don't know i don't know
i know but i like i stay away from that
but i do you have what
you did stand up recently but you had a
long time off yeah did you do a bit
we're like oh that's not really
relevant anymore like that's really not
the move anymore like in the current
climate that's like i have a bit where
i reference trump and my wife and
mexicans i'm like that's actually not
the move anymore
like i gotta re yeah reapproach
how i'm gonna tell this now well this is
this ain't gonna work in the climate
that i'm doing it
that makes sense a hundred like now more
like the the material is more about
you know just what we're dealing with
like you would you can't
it's to me it's so strange because you
know i came out doing an hour right away
and it's like
that hour that i did before co would
start till now it's like
oh this that stuff doesn't matter to me
i don't know if it matters to the
fans it doesn't matter to me anymore but
that's it's not important
if it's not if it's not important to you
anymore it's definitely not important to
them and so
i found myself really chopping a lot of
stuff out
i it's interesting so for me
you know cause i'm doing mostly personal
stories
that wasn't a feeling however
if i don't tell a story for a while
i lose the taste for it yeah me too like
i'm like yeah and then i don't want to
do it yeah then i
dread doing this me too and or not the
set i'll dread that part
and you know how it is when you're on
stage i can be doing a bit going this is
next going
[ __ ] that is next oh god let's just get
through that dude
i know your performance isn't as good
without one of the reasons that i put
guitar at the end of my set is because i
look forward to it i love it so much
have you ever been doing a set you did
so many times you're saying it oh yeah
but in your mind
you're you might be thinking about all
right after this i had two all the time
after this this and it's crazy crazy
crazy weird
all the time and i can even get sk if
you're used to set so many times you can
be going through it and
uh it's coming out of your mouth but
your head somewhere else
and there might be a heckler somewhere
you have to veer off and you can
actually do that
it is so crazy you compartmentalize it's
nuts where it's like
yeah how the [ __ ] does the brain know
i've started
doing like especially with longer longer
stories
i will get in there and as i get in
there
if i'm telling the story and looking
around i'm trying to
go okay i'm gonna speed it up actually
in two minutes from now where i usually
sit down i'm not going to sit down
they're a little low energy
so i'm planning out the joke which is
the one i'm telling but i'm planning the
two two minutes in
i'll even be telling the joke i'm like i
wish i had a drink yeah
like you're like i should get you a
drink oh you get a drink and you're
doing the set
the best you can but your brain's like
i'm asking what whiskey should i get i
wonder if they have angel envy i bet
they
have you ever done this it's weird have
you ever
you thinking about i time you need to
wake up tomorrow morning so
yeah i'll be in the settlement like 6 30
yeah and then i'll be like i gotta pick
up and then should i go to the jump
place i need call jeff i need to call
jeff foley because we go to jump
and then you're but you're in the middle
you're set it's [ __ ]
do you know what's funny sometimes do
this on you
do this on a late set do this on the
lightsaber i'm gonna have a swig of this
try a joke
but write three punch lines for it oh
and trying back to back to back oh yeah
sometimes if i can't decide if i'm gonna
go okay guys i'm gonna tell you the
story
in the middle of story i have a punch
line but uh
i don't know which one i like so i'm
gonna tell all three punchlines and i'm
gonna lead up
and i'll do that man because the truth
matter is
the people watching you the more i'm on
stage the more i realize
that if you if you're giving the people
watching an experience like oh this is
like live
he's truly doing this figuring it out
figuring it out
in front of us there's something to that
if you're saying this is in front of the
right crowd for me it's always a late
show
you can't do it in an early show but if
you get on a late show and you go city
too dude
you know i mean why i can't for me you
know what i'm saying it depends on the
my late show at the comedy store it's
like
they're such uh comedy educating they go
to the comedy store
you can certain shows where they'll
they'll go oh
it depends tuesday night sam triple show
it's
the hardest hitters in town you can't
experiment but if it's the belly room
or if you're in the or it's you know
it's a main room it's a different show
late saturday night
they're they're going to be like oh he's
figuring that out no one's going to walk
god that [ __ ] bomb man it's like well
no he's figuring it out there
there is no doubt that that or
gives you a little more room to play you
know you know i've only done they've
asked me to do i only did the or once
someone canceled
i was in the hallway they go hey uh we
do a set in the arm like oh [ __ ] yes you
know
yeah the mecca might kill ya i'm in the
middle of my set dude and a guy had a
heart attack in the front row
and i couldn't finish my set no well
well
literally has a heart attack and like
what did you do i went
did so the guy falls on the ground i go
man i think i was killing it that hard
everyone starts laughing the lady goes
no stop
he's literally having a heart attack and
i go oh [ __ ]
so i look at the the security hey we
need help in here
so they help the complete show comes
their screeching halt
they drag it like drag no and then
i i think it was adam back goes no
and you had to just keep going i had
eight minutes left dude i kept going
how quickly they get this dude out of
there pretty fast
well you know when i say fast 10 minutes
what's your first what's your
just saying i mean coming out of a heart
attack what's your joke i mean i made a
reference
i certainly had to right i started
making fun of him you had to
and people laughed right yeah yeah i was
like i didn't think i was doing that man
he could have just asked for his money
back yeah i was like man they would have
given her [ __ ]
[ __ ] diet tend to have a heart attack
i'm trying to think nobody's ever had
i've had people pass out i've had people
throw up
i've had people [ __ ] i've had people get
fingered
i have had no heart attacks no heart
attacks i had
this i had somebody translate oh wow
a translator so the guy they because he
had watched my stuff
online and it had captions on it so he
when he came to the country he wanted to
come but he brought a translator
oh dude so i was telling a joke and
you'd hear somebody just
in broken english oh no and finally i
asked i go
what the [ __ ] is going on and he was
like i'm translating your jokes
oh no i was like you can't but that guy
who had the heart issue during my show
was such a he was like my one of my
number one like huge fan
you wrote me i think you remember this
cat you were like this huge apology was
like
i'm so sorry man i know it was a big
night you're telling me where he ruined
the show yeah
you ruined the [ __ ] show man you
[ __ ] me and i'm scared to ever do a
set in the audience
the or dude the or
is to me my favorite i
to me the main room is the hardest room
in the country yes
for me for some people they love it the
oh for whatever reason the main room
is the hardest room for me in the
country i love that o.r
there's just something it feels like the
world are you on the road next
columbus funny bone yeah great club
great club i'm in dallas
first week of october at the improv uh
addison yeah how much
how much new material you think you got
40 minutes 30
30 minutes how do you feel that all
right you know you're
the only way to figure out is on stage
you only do so much writing at home
are you the only way to navigate is
what's interesting is i told i told
columbus i told my uh agent i go hey man
you know my son only be in nine months i
don't want to miss much so i'm not gonna
do the road like i used to don't book me
four weekends on the road don't do
anything he goes got it
he's he's gonna hear this justin you
know i love you he sends me he goes hey
here's the schedule these cities open
back up
so you had me on the weekend eight weeks
in a row
[ __ ] september to december i'm like
dude we just talked last week is oh
that's right
so we took out a bunch of [ __ ] yeah it's
just not worth it i'm just not working
it's not working
i'm doing max two a month from now on
for right now me too on the road a month
and then once
the store and improv and factory open
i'm doing a shitload of sets
yeah but i'm still gonna be home this
honestly man
this quarantine has been so
eye opening for me me too brother it has
been so eye opening for me
because i
thought i'm going to tell you something
with
i'm going to be as honest as i possibly
can but this quarantines and i didn't
know it
it saved my marriage and i didn't know
my marriage was in trouble agree
i didn't know it and it was
heartbreaking to me some of the things
that
that beth said to me but were
real she was because you were you were
you had the blind you
you had you you had this on right yeah
yep me too
zero balance but she basically said it's
not that i
you still she said i you're still loving
my life i love you more than anything
but i'm happier when you're not here
because when you're here
you're you're not present and you're you
upset the apple cart you come back with
this crazy energy yeah
and she said and this isn't your fault
but i'm just more used to
living alone than i am with you and so
when your wife and mine talk or what
dude and here's another thing did they
read the same book same exact book
and and and when when i used to talk
about living
and when i used to come home she said
she would say look
you upset the flow here i have
everything
down perfect and then you come in with
your energy
not that my energy was bad it's just
it's different it's different it's a
tidal wave and then i have to
rock in the boat it takes me a day to
get everybody back
in line imagine having a four-year-old
at nine-month-old my girl goes whoa
dude we do this this and this you come
in can't [ __ ] have
a rock in the ship look at this [ __ ]
it's his first pair of kicks
by the way the first pair of kicks these
jordan ones those are the buzz
lightyears
there's some junk in that trunk that's a
big dude
look at him he kind of looks like the
gerber baby yes i mean
[ __ ] cute that ball he doesn't tell
you it's eight feet big
yeah it's a big ball yes but but dude is
the buzz lightyears
she she told me this saved and i agree
we had gotten used to a normal that
isn't normal
for people to live but you don't realize
that because you're in the game when you
get out of the game
they go hey dude you shot 30 [ __ ]
shots like
i did yeah like yeah man you're not
passing the ball you're like
oh [ __ ] yeah you don't realize until you
stop and you look outside and someone
goes dude you gotta
start passing them your girl said the
same thing 100 saved our marriage
100 percent and and i was moving a
million
miles did you know it was a problem no
me neither no i was moving
because i would see and didn't you think
you were doing things for your family
yeah yeah
i was moving a million miles an hour and
then i was like oh and i go through my
head i go hey look we made this i
i have a rule when i do stand up you
know it's 20 they just wire the money
you have to give me a physical check if
you don't give me a physical check i
don't feel like i accomplished anything
i feel bad about it
so they always give me a physical check
because i take that check oh that's dope
and i come home i go hey baby here you
go and i thought here you go
was checking the boxes it's not it's
i we i had this and then i put because
i'd feel so much resentment for being on
the road missing my kids
i would go overtime with them but then i
wouldn't do anything with my wife
man it is so similar they read the same
book
but but it makes you realize also dude
like
they have been do they have endured
and endure not the right word but
they've put up with our lifestyle
but which isn't here's the difference
you you your wife met you when you were
a comic right yes you've been a standout
for how long josh
uh yeah my girl met me when i was a ufc
fighter and i was renting a one bedroom
studio
in playa vista and i had nothing i had
no money
and then she didn't sign up for this so
then it goes from that oh i didn't know
this was going to happen
and i go from that then i'm now on this
comic and i'm touring all the time and
i've
podcast three different podcasts i'm
doing this and you know
she's like dude i didn't sign up for
this totally i didn't know either and by
the way she's not wrong
no she's not wrong and what you realize
also is that
not only was because
you were always blinders go go go go go
i brought that home with me
so the energy i had at home still even i
think it would have been better if i got
home
and i had a hey i'm home it's me and you
i'm home forget everything else me and
you home
but i couldn't get rid of that hustle i
know
even when i walked in my house it's hard
to turn it off even for me now it's hard
for me to turn off but
i'm getting better because of quarantine
i force myself to and then also
like i i was like oh i bought you a
g-wagon she's like dude
i would rather walk yeah and then have
this jew and have you be home and
present
then constantly thinking about [ __ ] all
the time and not be present
so now it's like we schedule date nights
because when you have two little
kids it's impossible dude so now we sk
we schedule date nights
would you and joey diaz told me from the
very start when i started doing stand-up
goes dude
once a week you need to do a date night
with your girl you need to you take time
for you and her
i was like joey's crazy is he or has
joey figured it out no he figured it out
you because at the end of our business
by its nature is
in order to be good at it you have to be
a little bit selfish
because your business is you you're not
you're not
your business isn't numbers you're not
in accounting no in order to be good at
your business
you have to focus on you and so
your partner and your spouse doesn't
need that type of [ __ ]
all of the time and so if you're not
focusing any of your energy on them
if it's always you you you you you're
always looking in the mirror
nightmare you don't want to be with that
person and i agree with you man like
some of the things that were said to me
were hard to hear yeah for sure
we're hard to hear but she you know when
she said to me
i in theory when we're on the phone with
each other
on saturday night i look forward to
seeing you in theory
but when i know you're on your way back
from the airport i dread it
because i know what the rest of sunday
is going to be
and and by the way my deal with her is i
take the first flight back
so if i i don't [ __ ] around i don't know
6 a.m flight me too
but but that makes me super tired for
sunday me too i'm not present so i'm not
present
i started so now i booked like 10 a.m
flights or 11 so i'm not waking up at
5 30 but i'm now i'm like am i missing
too much of the day
right but at least when i come back i'm
a [ __ ] zombie or an [ __ ] yeah or
yeah his [ __ ] or sleeping on the
couch yeah kids are like what the [ __ ]
dude
i i this is weird like it's it's been a
blessing with this kovit man
i i it's so because thanks newsome if
she
if she had just woken up one day and
said i can't do this
i would have been like this is coming
out of nowhere because you think you're
awesome
you think you're awesome she would have
been like you're killing it is it coming
out of nowhere
isn't it funny we haven't spoken to each
other in eight months
about something relevant is this really
out of nowhere so like
i am grateful it was a rough i don't
know about you
but the first couple weeks we were like
we're into each other we're into each
other
and then we fell back into two people
who were used to living by themselves
yep
and so it was a tough couple of months
to figure out is this work do we
still like being with each other yep
and then we realized we do we just have
to relearn how to do it yeah
and most of the relearning is you me
yeah me too yeah me too but i feel like
i'm a better person no me too 100
i feel like and and i ate some medicine
from her that i needed to eat
yeah i agree i like sometimes you need a
little bit of
oh this is who i am
especially when you're you're fooling
yourself
that you are like i'm this guy man i'm
this guy i'm the perfect this
is not gonna work out and then that
mirror goes up and you're like oh [ __ ]
oh i i know it was it was eye-opening
yep i agree
you some colonel mentioned yes we do
first one is yours
this may be like this is actually so
uh tyson has his uh podcast he does on
the tyson ranch yeah
and he and he's getting real with this
dude and this dude's like no you don't
believe that
and tyson punks the [ __ ] out of him and
the
the way the guy changes his tune made me
laugh so hard he's like
oh no you're right dog you're right dude
he threatens the [ __ ] at him watch this
hey listen um you look at a guy like me
at this stage in my life i'm doing good
got a couple of
100 million dollars properties and stuff
right
and i hate myself no i know you don't
look at your
this is just some people have you don't
know what i've seen that's so true
though
yeah that's so true i haven't walked in
your shoes
yeah i would love to hear tyson go but
it is how i feel no i know that is but
you are right but then again i think i'm
beautiful i'm a bad [ __ ]
okay and when i think like that that is
my sin that's my shame
my guilt but i'm the baddest man on the
planet right
i hate being who i am and i'm nothing
being from brownsville i'm nothing
so i actually invaded i created this i
am my god
okay yeah
yeah no doubt man i feel that yeah you
know you're great
is that great yeah you made me laugh so
hard
by the way that switch happened quick
tyson was like this is who i am and i
was like no he's out he's like who the
[ __ ] are you and he's like you're right
that would piss me off too like i'm with
tyson on this like he was getting real
and he's like yeah
he's like no you don't he's like dude
how the [ __ ] are you gonna tell me that
that's not the truth
is he still like
just pure scary is he top five you're
like that's still a scary [ __ ]
you did but you know you don't want to
see him fight you're not even gonna
watch the fight
so you don't think you think you could
take tyson yes
100 sure 100 does he know jiu-jitsu
does he know wrestling no yeah it's give
me a nightmare i'm not gonna stand and
bang with him yeah no no no no how many
of those punches do you think he could
take
none but i'm not gonna
he's not gonna have opportunity how does
it take him down like this
how does that work is does he have he
i'm sure he has a puncher's chance on
your way in
to land one punch right you should be
tough dude is that right
because you have to educate me please so
say you got a boxer who doesn't know jiu
jitsu
at all but it's like the conor mcgregor
floyd mayweather fight right
so if if it was a street fight because
floyd mayweather doesn't have knockout
power so find me somebody who could
knock you out with one punch
i mean floyd can especially for the
common fan but yeah but not with but
connor
right so say tyson could knock you out
with one punch for sure
anybody but if a guy knows jujitsu
because you're standing up
in front of each other isn't there even
a second where you're standing up in
front of each other where he has a
chance to land a punch
you'd be tough especially someone who's
like experienced that tell me why
you i mean because you can close the gap
so much and control his hands and just
trip him down to the ground
and then you're gonna land in full mount
yeah i don't know like i don't know
enough
so because you're you're gonna come in
just fully
and he's gonna throw one or two sure but
you know
you're gonna block that i i
so if you were gonna say somebody who
only knows jiu jitsu and
only boxer the jiu jitsu guy will beat
him 99
times out of a hundred is that right one
bar fight or in the ring
nine nine times out of a hundred unless
he unless you like say he gets
lucky and that punch gets through but if
it's a guy who's covering
up and then trips him down right [ __ ]
dude even if you're starting
say you're even if you're starting at a
distance and you can back up a little
bit
none of that matters i don't separation
i mean he might be able to land an
uppercut but if it's a guy who knows
like at least some fundamentals and
distance control
yeah and he throws that punch and he
just slips under and grabs a hold of him
you're [ __ ]
just you gotta be a boxer 99 times out
of 100. and does it matter if it's
in public or in a ring does either place
favor either one
doesn't matter i i man
that's the scariest like a line and a
shark and then you're
you're putting that line in the water
dude no shot no shot unless that one
lucky punch
lance this is the scene on that because
jiu jitsu guys
can look like ed o'neal sure do you know
what i mean like
it used to be if you went to a two
reference but sure but but or kenny
florian yes like you've seen
kenny the only reason you're like oh
that's a dork i'm going to [ __ ] that gap
i don't know somebody's grandpa dude and
he could beat the [ __ ] out of most
average people yes
isn't it like a purple boat i think he's
a black belt over
under horry and gracie that's pretty
impressive right
yeah i mean now bundy is 90 dude but you
know and he's moves like a tortoise
but i'm saying like the best example is
like kenny florian
or uh who's who's kenny floyd's boy the
the jitsu wizard oh uh
ryan hall ryan hall you've seen ryan
hall bring up
if you saw him in a bar and he was
trying to steal a girl he'd like you
would
you you're bigger than him you'd be like
dude i'm going to twist your [ __ ]
neck off
he's like oh really and he's the best in
the world in jitsu and
this guy yep that that guy
will twist your [ __ ] so not only will
he twist your face off but he's got the
same muscle tone as jared goff
yep and he will shatter your ankle into
70 000 places
you'll be doing rehab for the next three
years
that it that's bananas to me you beat
the show mike tyson
for real without a doubt beat the [ __ ]
out of them and is this
all like when you and again jiu jitsu a
little bit is jiu jitsu
is that where you're using somebody
else's body weight against them
somewhat i mean the the original uh form
of jitsu was made for smaller guys beat
bigger guys but there's some of that to
it but also
he's just so technically sound like look
at him dude
i i don't like kenny on the left like
you get the [ __ ] out of my face
he's going to beat the brakes off you
how heavy is this dude
that whole fight 55. so he's probably
walked around
165 170 but just thin
and just a dork it's like this dude
looks like a long distance runner yep
do you know what i mean like if you were
like he's holding his boston marathon
trophy
like good for him yeah he looks great
monster i
those guys are out there yeah that's the
scary thing about bar fights now is that
over that's don't get a fight no no no
you know i'm not no i'm not either i
mean i might wipe
dog [ __ ] on your window but i'm not sure
and run away
i'm not either i'm not getting in a
street fight no ryan hall's a nightmare
dude
what else you got jen this right here
so on saturday chris evans accidentally
leaked his own news
look at the smile on her face smell it
real fantastic i love captain america
yeah first and foremost um did you see
the picture
uh no i did it so it was a screen
recording okay let me see that tweet
kevin uh
evan uh chris evans publicist after
logging in twitter
let me see that yeah
[Applause]
he also had this photo on his uh photo
roll
yeah and this is what people are also
making fun of him it was like a phone
a really dark photo of his dick and then
a meme that somebody made
of him saying guard that [ __ ] that's
awkward there's a couple things first of
all
everybody go
[Laughter]
everybody listen erase the dick pics on
your phone bruh
that's hilarious
that's actually hilarious how i mean has
somebody not put a meme
of the shield over the tip of his dick
yet i mean somebody
had to have right what was the exact
picture
so uh he did a post on instagram where
on his story he put a he did a screen
recording
from his phone of a video of him and a
friend playing the heads-up game
the like ellen guessing game and when
the video stops it goes back to your
camera roll and you get to see like the
little blocks of your photos
the last thing that was posted yeah
within that timeline
and one of the photos was the guard that
[ __ ] but it was yeah another one is
just a picture of
his dick oh that's a bummer but here's
the thing everyone who saw it loves his
dick
he's been getting good reviews is it
it's the size dick have you seen it i
haven't seen it you have the picture
chin
it they got deleted they got deleted i'm
sure his team's just
pulling him if you hadn't pulling it
accidental dick pick out that people
loved would you pull it down if you had
an
act i mean it's already out there so for
him he's like all right
so now if you're already chris evans
you're already a huge movie star
you already have that body and now you
have a good dick
like i'm leaving it out there i'm
leaving it my publicist might be like
take that down i'm like
what is the negative to having a good
dick pic out there
it was this one right which one that
this one
it's so hard to tell so that's the i
think that that's the tip
don't play coi it's at the top or the
bottom
i did see the picture and it was i
thought it was like huge it's just
embarrassing
it's like thick too thick and big do you
think he i'm just saying
his mouth is watering
right now is that a i'm telling you and
then i'm definitely naming my dick
after one of the avengers like how is he
not
naming his dick captain america don't
bring it out
that poor guy i mean i would obviously
uh blurt out sure
okay that's a shitty deal what else you
got cat
um let's see is this so this is just an
update from a story that we talked about
recently with tick tock
potentially getting banned i don't know
what's happening with it today because
today was supposed to be the deadline
where it gets banned if it wasn't bought
out by a u.s company
and it turns out that the chinese
government actually didn't want the
company by dance who owns tick tock to
sell at all because it makes china look
weak so we're waiting to see if there's
an update on whether it gets banned or
not but they
turned down microsoft's offer oh wow i'm
sure it was a hefty offer
it has to be have you are you on tick
tock no
37 yeah me too can't do it i just can't
i know some people are i just can't i
had somebody i'm on
i like facebook instagram twitter
tap it out you guys got enough of me i i
hate myself my friend asked me he goes
hey man you wanna do a tick tock dance
with me i was like lose my number now
i'm out dude
i'm not you're a grown man no this is
not a ticker
some of those kids are making crazy
women i'm sure
i don't know how they make money though
it's just like because they're only
record
they'll have deals with uh record labels
where they'll pay them to make a dance
to a certain song
and then that's where the revenue comes
from they're making
a ridiculous yes ridiculous amount
check this out um there's a pot of crazy
killer whales
that are actually running up to boats
and ramming them to the point where it
actually
will turn the boat 180 degrees and it's
on the spec like specific routes killer
whales are
killer whales but they never do this
killer whales they're
completely random here see what they do
to a great with the they'll find great
white sharks with just their spleens
ripped out
their father liver they take their
livers yeah the the they're also
they hunt in packs yeah they're really
smart they
they'll separate and and um the way they
haunt
that's why they're a little different
than sharks because sharks generally
don't hunt and pack no
never but they they they hunt in packs
and they're really smart
calculated so if they're turning boats
watching a video of a seal on like
ice and he's just chilling there like
and
one uh killer whale came this way and
then like
did all the waves so he came off this
way to feed the other one
so there's one waiting over here while
this one pushed him this they're [ __ ]
up
i i have to tell you the idea of this
happening
makes me a little nervous that they're
going after
40-foot yachts yeah i mean end of the
day though could just shoot them in the
face though
that's a good point that's a good point
i mean i think they're technically
you can't kill killer whales but also if
it came down to it
shoot them in the face did you see that
they were doing it to that boat for 50
minutes
an hour yeah the 46 foot boat spinning
the boat around 180 degrees
are they just bored though are they
trying no the people inside so it's so
unusual but
it's a calculated attack like you just
talked about so they're doing it and
they're they're actually doing that echo
and the whistling sounds whatever so
they said it was freaky when they heard
it weird
but they think it's because uh during
that or right along that path
it's almost like the boats are taking
all the bluefin tuna which is their food
so they're figuring out kind of figuring
out like we gotta get these boats out of
here [ __ ] yeah get out of here this
is our food
that's for the fascinating dude i hope
they knock all those boats out
i hope the killer whales win that's
[ __ ] awesome man cool
if that is the case that just shows you
like they're they're smartest [ __ ]
yeah yeah they're they're it's past
instinct with them
that's pretty damn cool what else you
got there's an update another update
once again on that mighty ducks guy
sean weiss oh my god oh man i guess i
care about this story
no listen so he actually looks better
remember he i mean than that right here
right here i'll show you here
what's this ad blocker he doesn't look
good in either of those people yeah i
mean
one if he gets covered he's [ __ ] so
this is what he looked like before
right it was totally bad what this is
meth but look at him now oh wow
all right he's much much better and this
style this dentist he actually did it
for free it's like an 80 thousand dollar
teeth job it is veneers
yeah oh man and i liked it i like he's
where he looks like he's got a nice silk
pajama top
he looks good yeah man way better than
him
in his hair yeah he looks go ducks this
dude
is he got an ascot or is that a match
that's gotta be a massive okay
i like your kerchief today though man
they gave my dog one of those
when he left the uh vets the other day
they looked a lot like that one
well we we're taking off his nuts
how old is he he's two years old okay
it's time yeah that's what you do
i but i i asked him i'm like hey can we
keep them and she was like why i'm like
just for fun be funny and formaldehyde
or something yeah i thought it'd be
funny
and she was like we don't yeah you can't
do that yeah we don't do that yeah
that's a hard pass
i thought maybe it might be funny to put
it like in my office what kind of dog
oh it's a half pit half american bulldog
he's a good dude you're gonna calm
calm him down if you take the nuts
though he we need to okay he needs to
i'm not he's
he's a little out of his [ __ ] mind
and for whatever reason
he is heavy into humping this pillow we
have
not anymore no i hope not not anymore
yeah because he's always like and when
you get near that pillow he's like no
don't
he's just the pink rock he's like that's
my girl yeah and you know what
he's he's got a
beth has said this to me she was like
why are his nuts better than yours
now there's big nuts they're just tiny
they're smoother
no but i have older nuts so they're a
little
saggy they're heavier you know this
dudes get tight
yeah smooth young nuts the young nuts
and you're taking those
and beth loves them she's like they're
so cute i'm like not anymore
no they're gone poor dog that's what you
gotta do
i feel bad for them i know i wasn't
gonna but you know you can get um
fake nuts and put them on your dogs what
i mean that's more of a human thing i
think
there is there's fake nuts company that
you can
put fake nuts i want to do a company
where it can't be comfortable for the
dog no it but they're prosthetic nuts
i want to do a company where they it's a
prosthetic nut but it's a bag so you can
put your keys in them
that's cool right like when you go on a
run it's like a fanny pack but
yeah they're like nuts you put your
phone in there that's not terrible all
right
is that it that's it uh your
punch line it's just columbus just oh
that's the only one of those that's left
yeah
columbus i think it's first second and
third or second third and fourth it's
three ninths
and uh high live tonight uh-oh
and then chaos tomorrow tomorrow we got
freddie freddie princeton jr i love him
eric griffin zainab johnson it's gonna
be a great job man we got bill burr
on wednesday wednesday huh yeah i'm
really excited man
i have so many comedy questions asking
do you
yeah yeah because yeah
because he is at a point where he knows
himself so well
that what he says is funny yeah when he
gets on stage
you've seen him do new material and
you're like that's funnier than anything
i've ever said 100 percent
so i'm gonna ask him about covet and
wearing mask
yeah that'll be good that'll be a good
conversation just kidding
uh so you're in columbus i'm in dallas
uh october first through the third
tickets just went on sale
denver is not happening and then
nashville zaney's
november 19th through 21st you're going
to be there right i'm going to come hang
out with you man it'll be fun man
so dallas october 1st through the 3rd
addison improv dallas
texas nashville uh zany's
and that is uh november 19th 21st
tickets at t5k.com
for all thick boy gear go to
thickboy.com thick boy thick girl
we'll have new merch drop in later this
month josh wolf you're the best
thank you very much hey josh wolfe merch
if you want to go check some of that out
get it
all right we're out